what is up everybody it's animak here
for anime uproar and the twists and
turns in the mh manga just keep getting
more and more bizarre shigaraki is
becoming even more unhinged to the point
that his inner demons are gaining a
physical form miroko is the fiercest and
bravest hero ever and bakugo is about to
be brought back from the dead with a
brand new ultimate power so let's get
into it you guys know how this works
drop a quick like and comment right now
to help us out with that youtube
algorithm it only takes a second but it
means a lot and of course if you haven't
taken the time to subscribe yet make
this the video that you subscribe and
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications people often tell me
that they miss my videos even when
they're subscribed and it's because you
have to go through the trouble of
subscribing hitting the bell and then
selecting that option that says all if
you don't follow all of those steps
you're still going to miss a ton of our
videos even if you are subscribed it's
just how you do works finally this video
will contain mha manga spoilers so
please proceed with caution you have
been warned the previous chapter left
off on that completely insane twist in
which ed shot randomly showed up
revealed that he was part of the same
knitting club as best genius in high
school and then proclaimed that he would
sacrifice his life in order to enter
bakugou's body and become his new heart
this was probably the single biggest wtf
moment in all of mha and most of us were
expecting a lot more answers and
explanations in the latest chapter of
the story and um well
let's just talk about what happened we
start off with a shot of headshot using
his quirk fold the body along with a
reminder about how his quirk works
headshot can flatten and stretch his
body at will and thanks to rigorous
training over many years he is able to
stretch his body so thin that it looks
like a spider web this allows that shot
to literally enter people's bodies and
manipulate them from the inside at
incredible speeds and we saw this
ability in action when he entered
kurogiri's body and instantly knocked
him out from the inside during the
hideout radar so when you really think
about it the idea of headshot being able
to perform emergency medical procedures
from the inside does make sense he is
able to enter people's bodies instantly
and make modifications to the bodies of
those people so with a lot of practice
and training it's not too far-fetched to
think that headshot could even perform
emergency surgery on the battlefield but
this is something that should have been
established earlier if edshot had been
established as a renowned medical ninja
at an earlier point in the story kind of
like tsunade from naruto then him being
able to literally bring characters back
to life wouldn't seem just like plot
armor for bakugo and because horikoshi
didn't lay the groundwork for this
earlier we get what is probably the
silliest and stupidest panel in all of
mha headshot brings out a little bubble
and says that laundry hero washu had
given him this special bubble at some
point in the past and headshot will now
use that bubble to cleanse bakugou's
body before performing his procedure now
this does make some sense from a medical
perspective because you need to keep
everything clean during surgery in order
to avoid infection and some other type
of contamination so if headshot had been
established as a medical ninja who
carries some sort of first aid kit along
with him at all times then we could
understand that maybe he keeps such
bubbles inside a special section of that
first aid kit for emergency uses such as
this one but since no such thing has
been established we are now left
wondering why in the world headshot
keeps a little bubble with him during
battles and where he keeps this bubble
in the first place i mean it's a bubble
and even though it's a special bubble
are we really supposed to believe that
headshot can engage in a brutal fight
against shigaraki with that bubble
somewhere on his person without the
bubble ever popping like what anyway
after the bubble incident headshot
proceeds to make his body so thin that
it can serve as a surgical tool but
stretching his body to that extreme
degree drains headshot's life force and
can kill him in the process that is the
whole sacrifice aspect that we talked
about in the previous chapter however
headshot feels that he has no choice
because despite genus best efforts to
sew up bakugou's wounds bakugo's heart
is still bleeding and badly damaged and
his lungs are also wounded so without
immediate surgical intervention he will
die and genus won't be able to save him
using his quirk headshot is able to mend
bakugou's organs from the inside and the
outside and he can even give bakugo cpr
from inside his body which drastically
increases the chances that bakugou could
be successfully revived headshot wants
miruko and the other heroes to keep
fighting because shigaraki is mortal and
he can bleed as well they just have to
hold out a little bit longer until
bakugou is brought back to life because
apparently bakugou is the strongest and
most important hero in existence so
saving him should be everyone's priority
even at the cost of their own lives
meanwhile shigaraki is surprised to see
genus and headshot still desperately
trying to help bakugou he already
destroyed bakugou earlier so why are
these people still trying to save him
the thought of bakugo being saved after
shigaraki believed that he had already
destroyed him in rages shigaraki who
feels that the only way to stop his
incessant itching is to keep destroying
everything there is literally no amount
of therapy that can help this man
although i'm sure that deku will try
shigeraki then tries lunging at bakugo
and the others but the fierce myriko
stops him with yet another furious
attack she ends up losing her other arm
in the process and i mean no wonder her
body is falling apart when she has to
carry this entire freaking chapter all
on her own seriously though i am
legitimately annoyed now by how
horikoshi keeps treating miroko why does
she have to take on all these injuries
while the number 3 and 4 strongest pro
heroes are both just sitting there and
risking their lives to save one hero
student instead of oh i don't know
trying to take shigaraki down and save
literally everyone else maybe i'm just
upset about my bunny waifu but let me
know what you guys think about how this
all went down in the comments below
kudos to miroko though she is an
absolute hero legend and i think she's
now even surpassed mario leona when it
comes to being the top badass female
character in modern shonen eventually
media also joins the fight to hold back
shigaraki and that's about the time that
shigaraki notices something he seems to
be actually taking on damage and
accumulating it which surprises him
because that's not supposed to be
happening to him with his new perfect
body shigeraki then seems to hint at the
fact that bakuga's attacks may have hurt
him earlier and that is why he is now
accumulating damage i wasn't 100 clear
on this point and if that was the case
then it might kind of explain why the
heroes are so desperate to save bakugo
if his new howitzer impact cluster was
able to deal real damage to shigaraki
then maybe we can justify the fact that
3 of the top 5 pro heroes are currently
risking their lives just to save him but
none of this was ever made clear to us
and even if this was the case we have no
idea if the heroes are even aware of it
and yes in case you need a reminder
genius headshot and miracle are the
current third fourth and fifth strongest
pro heroes and all three of them are
currently risking everything just for
bakugo horikoshi please make it make
sense miroko once again laughs at death
and declares that she will give it her
all because she is not going to die with
any regrets she uses a move called luna
rush to actually land some hits on
shigaraki despite her severe injuries
and shigaraki is in disbelief even
though he thought that he had broken the
heroes and that they had no chance of
defeating him they are still fighting
against all odds and they are risking
their lives to help each other even when
it seems like there is no hope of
success this makes shigaraki remember
his own family and childhood and how no
one was there to help him when he needed
it even before he was a broken man his
family didn't support him and after
everything that happened then he became
broken no one was there to help him out
except for all for one everyone just
pretended not to see him and this is
what fueled his endless rage and desire
for destruction in that moment something
seems to snap inside of shigaraki and
some of his hand mutations begin to take
the form of his dead family members the
final page refers to these clones of
shigaraki's family as a newly unleashed
power that is threatening the heroes so
we can assume that these clones will be
fighting against the heroes alongside
shigaraki and since the heroes are
already barely surviving even with a
single shigaraki the only way that this
makes sense is if the heroes end up
getting a massive reinforcement very
soon one possibility is that deku will
finally arrive on the scene after all
this time but another possibility is
that bakugou will be successfully
brought back to life now one would
assume that even if his organs start
working again bakugou will still be too
injured to fight however if headshot's
procedure and sacrifice are able to
fundamentally change bakugou's body from
within then perhaps he will awaken with
a new found power a new quirk altogether
and this will allow him to get back into
the fight and that is what we need to
talk about now the possibility that
headshot and bakugo will somehow fuse
and that this will lead to bakugou's
quirk explosion fusing with headshots
quirk fold a body this will then create
a new super quirk that will allow
bakugou to actually put up a fight
against shigaraki until daku arrives now
at first glance explosion and foldabody
don't seem particularly compatible
explosion is an emitter type quirk and
fulda body is a transformation type
quirk and they function on a completely
different basis bakugo's quirk allows
him to excrete sweat into his palms that
has the properties of nitroglycerin and
he then uses that nitroglycerin to
create explosions headshot's quirk
allows him to stretch his body and
control its thinness while also moving
at incredible speeds clearly these are
two very different quirks with extremely
different effects but bakugo's latest
super move howitzer impact cluster may
provide some clues to what a fusion
between these two quirks might look like
as chapter 362 revealed the cluster
upgrade that bakugou devised came with a
side effect that he wasn't aware of the
act of saving up sweat into launchable
beads put a huge burden on the glands of
his palms eventually the beads of
nitroglycerin that were stored up could
no longer remain in the palms and so
they began leaking all over his body
this created small explosions throughout
bakugo's body which gave him even more
speed but this also had the effect of
causing immense pain to bakugou and
eventually it damaged his body and
organs but if bakugo's entire body were
to become flexible and extendable as a
result of some sort of fusion with
folder body then in theory he would be
able to protect his organs while still
creating explosions all over his body
and to make himself faster and more
effective in battle basically bakugou
may be able to turn his body into an
exploding beyblade that moves with
immense speed while launching hundreds
of explosions all around it at the same
time bakugou will be able to keep all of
his vital organs safe by stretching them
out of harm's way so he will essentially
become a swirling exploding inferno that
cannot be stopped until it connects with
its target and that target is of course
shigaraki don't get me wrong i realize
this is a stretch but it is one possible
way that explosion and folder body could
fuse in a way that makes bakugou a key
player in the fight once again what do
you guys think could bakugou's quirk
fuse with headshots quirk in order to
create a new super quirk if so what
would that quirk look like do you like
my exploding beyblade idea or do you
have some other ideas of your own let me
know down in the comments below i would
love to hear some great concepts for
this fusion as we await the next chapter
as always if you enjoyed this video
leave a quick like right now it helps me
out a lot and if you haven't taken the
time to subscribe yet remember it's
completely free and it is a huge help to
us here on the channel you can also hit
me up on twitter and instagram at
animeopror as always thank you guys so
much for watching and until next time
see ya space cowboys